hey guys my name is Jess McDowell it is
the 16th of March today you're watching
gamespot news and today's episode is
sponsored by Coleman outdoor and camping
Goods except it's not because that would
be super weird in program we might not
be sponsored by calm and company but one
gaming juggernaut has partnered with
them and that Square Enix the two
companies are joining forces for Final
Fantasy 15 which if you don't know
features an awful lot of camping I guess
square figured they could make a buck or
two which has led to final fantasy's
camping equipment being branded with the
cool man named square enix have said
that the product placement enhances the
games fantasy based on reality theme I
guess its final sort of fantasy this
time around then while camping in Final
Fantasy 15 you'll be able to chat with
your bros and make food which gives you
pups among other activities so suffice
it to say you'll be putting all those
Coleman products to good use next up the
X rare dads who make up platonic games
have revealed that their spiritual
successor to banjo kazooie is still in
the works the currently unnamed game is
known as project ukulele and is aiming
to combine 3d platforming with res
signature 90s gameplay and humor
platonic revealed new concept art at the
egx rezzed event in London and expressed
a desire to reinvigorate the 3d
platformers genre by utilizing new
technologies sounder gavin price has
also said that their small team is
hoping to fund the project via
kickstarter so if you're into the idea
that'll be your chance to back it
finally although a lot of gamers seem to
adore valve the company has just been
awarded an eighth-grader for customer
service that's the lowest possible grade
you can get from the Better Business
Bureau and it came as a result of 707
team complaints valve exec Eric Johnson
has said that they don't put a lot of
stock in the rating and prefer to use
sources like Reddit and social media to
determine how they're handling customer
issues Johnson explains we hear those
complaints and that's going to be a big
focus for us throughout the year we have
a lot of work to do there we have to do
better one proposed feature to rectify
the problem is to build support
mechanisms into the steam client
comparatively both EA and Activision
Blizzard were awarded perfect a plus
rating from the BBB let me know down in
the comments of you that they had a
support problem with valve or any other
companies you can hedge against thought
well we've got news on a free play
weekend for ps4 and Dragon Age wins
another game of the Year award that is
all the stuff that I have for you today
but be sure to check back with me same
time tomorrow for a bunch more news